here in London it's still all about
brexit brexit brexit sir exit debate the
analysis on what brexit really means is
still out for exit procedure what we
opted for was making our own decisions
and steering our own ship for exit
brexit Rexach we want to state France
with our British neighbours brexit
brexit right it is bad I have to defend
the interests of European citizen the
brexit referendum has been hugely
divisive in this country in a conflict
zone special this week we look back at
some of the key arguments that have
shaped this often angry brexit debate
[Music]
[Music]
one of the accusations against the leaf
side is that you consistently fail to
articulate what the British economy
would look like after brexit last
December we got a flash of real honesty
from Nigel Farage at the Oxford Union
when he said that I will accept that
none of us knows what the risks are if
we leave the European Union marvellous
the most momentous decision that the
British are being required to take in 40
years sort of fly with me and we'll see
what happens if we don't think the
country is worth more than their their
whole point is if we put the X in the
Box in the right box on the ballot paper
we then have two years of hopefully a
responsible government hopefully a
responsible team that will negotiate a
an exit package which is yes this is a
huge gamble you want the it's a huge
gamble for both sides the nervous time
for you coming up to the referendum so
nervous that you've even started to talk
about what it would be like to lose
haven't you well what I was actually
trying to do was say that the leave
campaign has made no attempt at all to
describe what a post brexit UK would
look like so the question I was raising
was if we were to vote to leave which I
clearly hope that we won't
what would the mandate be because
there's a huge difference between
staying in the single market or leaving
it but why because you sense defeat no
I'm raising it now because I think it's
really important that when people go to
the ballot box on the 23rd of June they
understand what leave means and at the
moment there's a black hole you never
stretch the fact in this campaign in
every campaign some people have no I
don't think I ever did but some people
on both sides used good and bad
arguments but you saw people on vote
leave using bad arguments
the whole country was involved in this
campaign so of course they were good and
bad arguments that's not an excuse for
misleading people is it I don't think
I've misled it what about your campaign
releasing the right of the campaign some
people who were campaigning for leave
out use bad argument you bring them in
did you want to rein them in well in
life we are responsible for what we do
right we're not responsible for every
ally who might have reached the same
position as a vote leave campaign
painted you only wear strategy versus
the strategy you helped I on Saturday
please do well here are a number of
things that were said during the
campaign that I think may now be fairly
decried as false we were told that there
would be an emergency budget that they'd
have to be emergency tax rises we're now
being told there'll be tax cuts we were
told that our immigration officer that
the French government is now said that's
not going to pay for what the other side
said I'm only going to hold you
responsible for what you said
let's deal first with with what appear
to be radically conflicting claims by
you and other leading lights in your
campaign right after the vote you caused
something of a stir on television by
saying that you favored the free
movement of workers to and from the UK
it means free movement of labour you
said it doesn't mean you citizenship my
question is at what point did you
declare in the campaign vote brexit
it'll mean free murder out at every
mayor every give me one example if
you'll allow me to I will tell you on
that very program sitting around that
very table with that very same
interviewer at the start of the campaign
I had said exactly the same thing I
written a book called why vote leave
which sets it all out which sold 20,000
copies I hardly think I can make you say
it will mean free oh yes it does we will
never accept to undo the European Union
you cannot expect that if the British
people or majority of the British people
want to go out of the European Union
that we shall destroy the European Union
I have to defend the interests of
European citizens that I have to defend
the interest of the German citizens the
Belgian citizens who want to keep the
European Union because it's in their
advantage what I am saying here is the
it would be a bad thing for the peoples
of Europe if the political class of
Europe willfully go for a bad deal with
Britain because they want to punish us
they want to discourage other people
from leaving the club and I do not think
that across much of Europe that the
political elites are held in any high
degree of regard so you can certainly
accuse me of attacking the European
elites but my goodness me
they've given me some - all right hear
this from the German car manufacturers
you told everyone in Britain of course
the Germans will never allow tariffs to
be slapped on their car exports to brick
they wouldn't want it they wouldn't want
it okay so what did Chancellor Merkel
tell the world she said the internal
cohesion of the EU would come before
defending German exports to the UK the
association of car manufacturers says
the future of the EU is more important
than short-term exports what do you know
what this actually plays into my hands
even more this gives me an eve this
gives me an even bigger card that I
thought I had to play because here is my
card oh come on the relationship between
big business big banks and big politics
is what it is they don't want things to
change they like the status quo the way
that it is what happens if it all goes
wrong I mean we haven't even started the
negotiation you you said in 2015 you
said in 2015 at the Oxford Union none of
us knows what the risks are if we leave
the European Union none of us knows what
the risks are if we stay in so we were
left to just you know take your bravado
and your and your assurance very simple
we're left to do that very simple you
could never predict the future exactly
whatever side of the referendum or at
all as you said you UK anyone that
thinks he knows the future should be
retired because they should have made a
fortune you know
and the real question with that
referendum was should we be responsible
as a nation with its own identity for
making the key decisions that determine
our future and whether we get them right
or get them wrong
genuinely
once every four or five years have the
chance to hold to account the people who
took those decisions or do we think our
future better to be a small voice as
part of a bigger new state and now I've
been as you know objective about that as
I possibly can be that's what the
referendum was about and what we opted
for not by a massive margin but what we
opted for was making our own decisions
and steering our own ship and that I
believe to be right in all circumstances
here's a context which is really
important we've said that at the end of
this process when people know what the
brexit deal what leaving the European
Union might look like when we've got a
few answers that we don't have at the
moment then you give the people of
Scotland a choice and what's been
fascinating it's a way that that has
been embraced by politicians across the
European institutions and across Europe
as well but the Conservative Party is
almost completely United around the
process of leaving the European Union
and also by the way on leaving but it's
the mechanics excuse me do you know the
outcome of the negotiation so we're in
the middle of a negotiation my point is
you negotiate that's what you do you
negotiate with the European Union
European Union appears to know what it
wants this government does you say it's
actually I did read the other day there
are a number of people in the Europeans
they don't agree with the Commission for
example I think it was the Austrian
finance minister and maybe wrong about
exactly what job he holds maybe it was a
commissioner I can't remember but he
actually said quite clearly that he
thought the UK was an incredibly strong
position because the European Union
needed the trade we've also had the fine
he's the only one isn't he he's the only
let me finish the finance minister of a
very election mrs. Merkel the other day
about making sure that she didn't screw
up the negotiations because there were a
million and a half jobs in Bavaria lie
on exports to the UK of machine tools
and cars alone there are plenty as I
talked to a lot of European businesses I
was talking to a person the other day
that does low-tech product he's a
Belgian manufacturer he produces
potatoes he said the last thing we need
in Europe is a tariff wall because my
business would go down the tubes I
employ lots of people I said have you
spoken to your politicians he said we're
talking to them now so before we just
get this out of kilter the European
Union is in a position where they're not
all together completely United and they
also recognize that they do need a trade
deal more about traders and you do
something about this trade deal alright
so just stop interrupting me and just
let me tell you about a trade deal
alright you might learn something here's
what has to happen as we leave the
European Union we will also reenter the
WTO as a voting member we're a member
but we're not a voting member now
the schedules that are owned by the EU
actually have a financial tag to them so
unless they agree with us the amount of
money that we pay to take some of those
schedules relevant to us and lodge them
at the WTO they will end up as the EU
spending a great deal more money for
less potency now here's the point they
have to settle that that's not they
might they have to settle that at the
time we leave otherwise they pick up a
bigger bill so mr. Barney a knows very
well that until this for example is
settled nothing is settled we all we are
there's no point in revisiting history
there's no demands in the country for a
further general election what there are
demands fall from I know from standing
on doorsteps in my constituency is for
the UK government to proceed with the
negotiations and end up with the best
possible brexit deal so that's why all
these things should be very much
explored but my point is this in trying
to get a solution that placate both
remain errs and brexit ears Britain
seems to be reduced to putting forward
ideas that are pretty much unworkable is
that really the best your party can do
well I think that all options have to be
on the the table and objective well I
think the understanding is understanding
obviously why things are rejected look
the brexit referendum has been hugely
divisive in this country and I do think
one of the mistakes made and early on
was not trying to acknowledge that
whilst the leave campaign and 116
million people 48% of those who voted
had not voted for this so in trying to
bring people together to explain that we
would be leaving but we would do it in a
way that was not going to damage
completely unnecessarily people's own
livelihoods and our economy that's what
we're sort of catching up to now that's
all I expect to be debated both in
Parliament and in cabinet in the next
few weeks looking back over the last two
years you were part of David Cameron's
cabinet which approved this referendum
why did none of you ever ask the kinds
of basic questions that people are
grappling with now what if what if we
lose the referendum what if the body
splits what if Europe replies the rules
what about the Northern Ireland border
why were none of these questions thought
about beforehand well I can't say they
weren't they weren't thought about well
partly because I've obviously many of us
campaigned in order to remain and it's
difficult if you're campaigning for one
thing to gaze into the crystal ball and
answer every question that's going to
come up I deeply regret the result but
the result is we in this country
obviously had a fair and democratic vote
difficult very difficult for people to
accept but I think it is the right thing
to do to balance those two now which is
to say yes we are going to leave the
European Union but we're not going to do
it in a way there's damaging and if we
constantly look back to the past I read
of the vote from two years ago that
actually I think what happens is that
attention is not given that future
relationship between the two parties
which is very important power as we call
it Western system of democracy rule of
law parliamentarism is under stress what
happened in UK UK them the origin of
modern parliamentarism moved the most
important decision in for the first
decades in this century from UK from
Westminster to a referendum crazy mr.
Lambert
this is the key sticking point the Irish
border the border between the Irish
Republic and Northern Ireland if Britain
crashes out without a deal day one on
this border what happens there will be
controls obviously putting up those
controls well both sites will need to
put process it isn't an island says it
isn't of course it isn't well we will
need to have contingency plans for that
of course so what are they our
contingency in day one from day one of
course you don't expect that smugglers
will start importing goods into Europe
because
at the moment we have alignment but very
soon if this border is not policed well
it will be abused and I ve use plans
then what do you believe that we are
going to put these plans in the open to
208 border crossing yes and you propose
to police all those do you well we will
need to control we will need to go
against the wishes of the Irish State
against the wishes of the Irish they've
made it perfectly clear what we are
saying is very clear this from Simon
Cove near the Foreign Minister the Irish
government will not support the
re-emergence of border infrastructure on
this island can it be clearer than that
no it cannot be clearer than that but
then they know the consequences that
then we will put the check sails word
and on the intra Irish border who who
will put the check well the European
Union member states what you what do
these checks look like then who's gonna
put them up front X naught front X I
mean the customs the the customs also
Authority in the various member states I
mean what you believe do you believe
that we are going to let any good enter
the European Union just unchecked and so
if if the Irish don't do it then of
course people on the continent will so
there will be a border between Ireland
and other and and you and I tell you
that the Republic of Ireland is very
much preoccupied about the integrity of
the single market and doesn't want to be
excluded from the single markets and
believe me and this is the calculus that
many British are are just ignoring is
that yes a heart breaks it will be
damaging for the you 27 it will be even
more for the UK but that is not our
problem it will be damaging for the 27
the European Parliament has failed time
and again to connect to ordinary people
brexit is proof of that isn't it in
Europe no I don't think brexit is proof
of that we don't you know that the
analysis on what breaks it really means
is still out because I think you know
the reasons why people voted for brexit
or maybe very much connected to the
reasons why American people voted for
Trump and incidentally to turn out of
your in their freedom maybe you can hear
me out
the American turnout at the American
elections is not very high either but
it's clear that people are facing a
choice of the kind of world they want to
live in some people would like to go
back in time take rights away
from people you know and equality and
pluralism and free democracy and that is
really what's at stake here people are
losing faith in the EU here's the
paradox isn't it
highest level of support for membership
since 1983 but more than half the people
of Europe think the EU is likely to
collapse within a generation all the
what for the first decay is an implosion
that unfortunately we have seen in the
UK has been a vaccination rather than
infection for the rest of Europe we have
seen so you should be strong we have
seen if I can finish my sentence the
Eurobarometer country after country
European Union popularity has increased
even in Hungary with a few exceptions
like Czech Republic and we have seen one
after the other the extreme right
political parties dropping the agenda of
leaving the European Union and leaving
the Euro citizens have all these DIY
liberals and greens have gone forward in
the elections they want the stronger
Europe they don't want a weaker Europe
so what you do is you go straight to the
so-called future relationship and you
say what is the desired end state at the
end of all of these negotiations and
that is a comprehensive free trade
agreement between the United Kingdom and
the European Union so that we can trade
to our mutual benefit an advantage with
low or no tariffs into the foreseeable
future we were always going to have to
at some point agree the future
relationship so my argument would be
that the cultural markets and well let
manufacturing market well that's a
matter for negotiation but there is an
existing template it's the EU Canadian
free-trade agreement which was signed in
2016 which took how many years well that
took seven years to negotiate it but the
advantage of that is is that we've
already done all the heavy lifting
so we've argued they argue heavy lifting
it's a very different economy from the
British yes but what you would do very
different but what you do is you take
that as a start point so you have a
template that you know by definition the
EU
did accept because they signed it and
then you so you don't start with the
blank piece of paper you start with that
and then you see whether you can modify
it so for instance it would be from a
weaker position because man you're doing
is you're already out of the year
oh yes and I'm perfectly prepared to
leave on WTO terms while those
negotiations take place but I would a
spite the fact that industry is warning
that this is going to all project fear
nonsense well you could say your project
fantasy you don't know well the European
election the European elections in this
country or overwhelmingly won by the
brexit party whose policy was to leave
if necessary with No Deal the people in
this country overwhelmingly voted for
that so there is a mandate we can't
leave Brussels without a mention of
brexit British newspapers suggesting in
the last few days that there are new
overtures being made to Boris Johnson
this after the European unit has
stressed repeatedly that there is no
reopening of the withdrawal agreement is
the EU in the process of blinking at the
eleventh hour no we have said and also
underlined has repeatedly continued to
say this we want to stay France with our
British neighbors that's not easy in the
current political debate especially not
is in the current debate in the UK but
that's the principle we want to stick to
but it's obvious that the treaty that we
have been negotiating money and the may
government is the treaty that is on the
table and if yeah but you have new
people now coming into the EU and you
have new Polish government but the
principles behind that treaty don't
change it's only the five European
countries including Germany and France
allegedly making contact with Johnson in
order to see what chance there is of a
new deal you know as I said the
principle we are having all together and
I think it's not only these five
countries all countries in the European
Union wants to stay friends with our
British neighbors so the point is that
the basic principles of the treaty they
are there they cannot be changed but for
sure we have to stay in touch with Boris
Johnson and whatever other candidate
that may win this battle because we want
to make sure that in the long run we
stay friendly neighbors we will always
be there close to each others and we
cannot afford the situation
where we are in a bed a mood hanging
around together we have to face the
future together
even if the you was a new overture from
the EU doesn't it otherwise come October
you will both both the EU and Britain
will reach a scenario that none of you
wanted none of you want cashing out
without a deal exactly the assumption so
much for the last three years it's your
presumption that there will be maybe a
crush out without the D but it's not
said the deal is on the table and the UK
and the next Prime Minister can still
subscribe to it or make propositions how
we can improve it but despite what
they've said and despite what the EU has
change Tim that's obvious in politics
you can in politics discuss about
everything but you cannot change the
principles of the treaty they must
remain and the principles of the treaty
are the basics of the treaty but what
Boris Jones not whatever candidate wants
to do we have to see when they are in
office Davis didn't know the first thing
about the European Union this is what he
said within minutes of a vote for brexit
the CEOs of Mercedes BMW VW and Audi
will be knocking on Merkel's door
demanding there be no barriers to the
British market didn't happen I think
they said it was going to be the easiest
deal in history didn't they said all the
cards were gonna be in Britain's hands
didn't happen that this was nonsense
wasn't it project fantasy you know what
we've what we've got is we do still have
some semblance of democracy in this
country whereby people who are
dissatisfied to what the government's
doing come and Lobby me I Lobby the
Prime Minister they lobby the Prime
Minister directly due to the Democratic
deficit in the European Union we're
trading with Germany France and all the
other EU countries but they've given the
powers of these negotiations to another
body called the European Union and and
it's what it wants to get out of these
negotiations is going to be different to
what our customers in those countries
once again and there is a huge
Democratic deficit meant that the people
making the big decisions in the European
Union are not elected and not it not
politically account
we just had the largest the largest
Democratic vote is for the European
Parliament yes a large 411 that they
bond a lot and the largest party elected
at that Parliament is the brexit party
you're unhappy with her as democracy for
you that's democracy as democracy mr.
Brittain when you look around this
country you can't fail to see people
getting angrier more divided more bitter
demonstrations are getting angrier you
like it that way the country divided
full of hatred no invective no not at
all and but that's what you are a
distance to a deal has produced isn't it
no it's the resistance to leaving as I
said the democracy only works you had a
deal you could have left you would have
been out but it was a very very bad deal
and it would if it was a deal I don't
think we ever would have got out of the
back stop I think that was the end state
for that the you've got in mind for our
country and they would have had a veto
listen to the article 50 process we can
actually leave while we're in it however
long we extend it and however unpopular
it is with our electorate once we'd sign
that withdrawal agreement the EU would
have a veto and when we could actually
get out of that treaty and I do think
the country can come back together but
one thing for sure Tim how is it going
to come back together when we lose so
deep when we actually you're about to
take a position in the parliaments
steering brexit steering group well it's
to be it's going to be UK coordination
group yes can you get a deal in 11
months well ah not on everything a
bare-bones deal probably yeah you could
have done a deal with Theresa May
why didn't he you do that you would have
had a softer brexit in remember grouse
you too insisted on the Irish backstop
because its keel that finished her off
didn't it well she had no majority in
her Parliament but she could have got an
agreement sir if you'd letter on the
back stop really thing that protecting
the rights for companies offer citizens
protecting peace in Ireland was not a
key priority I don't agree with you
our government said it was a key
priority but the backstop wasn't
necessary but you're going to end up now
with a with an outcome if if Britain
leaves without a deal that's an outcome
that nobody wants usually the brain yeah
but you didn't want it either
no but it's going to cause massive
disruption for you - my point is you
it's a choice for the Brits I didn't
want to destroy their country I don't
think this is what they want they have
to be responsible leaders it's time for
responsibility it's gonna suffer -
that's for sure I mean there's no good
present
[Music]
you
[Music]
you